-Jack Harlow. Jack, look at us.
Can I just explain --
You made your TV debut.
You performed here.
Now tonight, this is your first
talk show interview.
So you're debuting your t--
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
Whenever I -- Whenever I
imagined the couch time,
I was always like, "Oh,
this sounds nerve-wracking."
But I feel -- I feel great.
I actually feel --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You feel good?
You feel comfy?
-I feel at ease with you.
-Good.
That's what I want you to do.
Good, 'cause you know
I love you, man.
You're one of the biggest
rappers on the planet right now.
And I just --
I have this photo of your --
This is a performance
that someone took a photo of.
This is one of your --
-Wyatt, my best friend,
took that photo.
-This is one of your
first gigs I guess?
Yeah?
-My first ever show
in Birmingham, Alabama.
My first ever tour show.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This is the tour.
One, two, three, four, five.
There's like 10 people there.
They're not even looking at you,
these guys.
They're talking to each other --
"Hey, what's up, man?
What do you think of
the concert?"
How does it feel to go
from here to here?
-It's validating.
I think I just like --
I appreciate it.
You know, I appreciate it.
It's fragile to me.
I know I worked for it.
I don't take it for granted
at all because of that.
Because I did everything, bro.
I did the open mics.
I did A3Cs.
I begged people to rock with me.
-Yeah.
-You know what I'm saying?
I really put in the work.
-You put the hustle in.
-So I can always
stand on that.
You know, no one can say
this was gifted to me.
-Yeah, good man. I agree.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You start here.
I mean, honestly, you should be
friends with all these people.
There's only 10 people there.
-You know what's crazy is I went
back to Birmingham in the fall.
We sold it out in three seconds.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you. Thank you.
And, like, maybe seven of
the people were there
from this photo,
this show in the this fall,
and they had on
the same outfits.
[ Laughter ]
-That's a good move.
That's awesome.
Oh, I love they did that.
Birmingham, shout-out.
That's so cool.
-Yeah, I hugged --
I met some of them
after the show.
We took pictures and reminisced.
-I mean, you start here,
then you end up performing
at the Grammys
with Lil Nas X,
doing "Industry Baby."
Come on, hit number one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
What does it feel like to have
a number-one song?
Did you know it was gonna
be a hit?
-"Industry Baby"?
-Yeah.
-I knew "Industry Baby" was
gonna be special.
In fact, when I was writing
the verse,
everyone in the room,
I kept saying,
"This is gonna be a number one.
This is gonna be --"
I was like, "This is gonna be
a number one, trust me, y'all."
-Really?
-Yeah.
-And what's it like performing
with Lil Nas X?
-You gotta bring your A game
to stand out.
You know what I mean?
-Yeah, exactly.
It's hard to take the light
off that guy.
-He's just so powerful.
I had eight bars at the Grammys.
And so he had this massive head.
-He does it up.
-He had this massive Lil Nas X
head that was on the stage.
Like, his face, and I was
hiding inside of it
waiting for my time
to come out.
[ Laughter ]
-What part of
the head did you come out of?
-The back of it.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, he's got a great head,
man.
-Yeah, he's got a great head.
He really does.
-So, I came out the back of it.
The whole time I'm inside,
I'm just thinking --
The whole time
I'm inside his head,
I'm just thinking like,
"I got to kill this."
[ Laughter ]
-This whole moment has been
crafted by him,
so I got to come out swinging.
-I want to say the last month,
or something,
since this album came out,
every video I see you
do goes viral.
There's something else
crazy happening.
And I just want to see
if you can give me
your thoughts
on a few of these, right?
This first one is a clip of you
getting interviewed
at the Met Gala
that we were just talking about.
Do you guys know
what I'm talking about?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-They've seen it.
They've seen it.
-Yeah, I know, but I think
we should see it again.
We have to play it.
Emma Chamberlain, okay,
is interviewing you.
And watch her reaction
and watch what you say.
-I'll see you in there.
-Can't wait.
Love you.
Bye.
-Love ya.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Is that the effect?
Like, what is that?
Is that the Harlow effect
or what is it?
-That's like a piece of art
because there's so many ways
to interpret that,
you know what I mean?
[ Laughter ]
Everyone has a different take on
what was going through her head.
So I'll leave it up
to interpretation.
-Yeah.
But do you leave every interview
saying "love you"?
-Only if I love them.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright. Alright.
You loved her.
-I have a lot of warmth
to share.
-You saying, "love ya"
was just genuine.
And then her reaction is like,
"Ha. Huh?"
[ Laughter ]
-You forgot the part
where she said it back.
We love each other.
-Yeah, hey.
Then you were
at the Celtics game.
-Yeah.
-Okay.
-That was just --
-So, they show you
on the jumbotron.
And then the refs are talking
to each other,
and their mics were on.
Take a look at this.
-Who's Jack Harlow?
Who's Jack Harlow?
-I have no idea.
-The guy over here.
Right here.
He's in the white shirt.
-Yeah, who is he?
-I don't know.
Go ask him.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"Go ask him."
"Who's Jack Harlow?"
"I don't know.
Go ask him."
[ Laughter ]
You had a funny reaction to that
because clearly they didn't see
"Chronicles of Narnia"
or something like that.
-Yeah, there's a portion
of this crowd that knows
that I get compared
to that half goat from "Narnia."
[ Laughter ]
We have the same
sort of thing going right here.
-Yeah.
-No, it was wild.
I was like -- Of course
I'm not watching the broadcast.
And then people start blowing up
my phone like,
"Yo, the refs have no idea
who you are."
I'm like, "Okay."
-Yeah, who cares?
-I got online,
and I'm seeing the clip.
I think the clip is iconic.
So, I'm like,
I've got to let this guy know
who I am, Scott Foster.
-Yeah.
-So, it's the fourth quarter
and he's over on the sideline.
And he comes over.
And I'm like, "Yo," and
I'm trying to get his attention.
He's like, "My daughter
already texted me."
[ Laughter ]
-"I know.
My daughter already texted me.
I know the who heck you are."
Now, you got cast in your first
big movie, bud,
which I'm excited about
'cause you got a good look.
This is just the start.
You are going to be
in the remake of
"White Men Can't Jump."
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love this.
How did you get involved
with it,
and do you know the movie?
Do you know the original?
-Yeah, I know about it.
[ Laughter ]
I had heard about it.
I mean, I know how iconic it is.
Then when I got the offer, I was
like, "Hm, I should watch it."
[ Laughter ]
To be fair, it came out
before I was born.
So, I watched it.
I see why it's classic.
-Yeah.
-It's not as gimmicky
as I might have imagined.
-Oh, it's funny.
-Phenomenal dialogue.
So I'm excited.
We got the offer.
Kenya Barris called D.J. Drama,
who I'm signed to.
Drama called me, he's like,
"Hey, you want
to be in this movie?"
-Kenya Barris is amazing.
He's talented.
-Yeah, shout-out, Kenya.
-You're playing
the Woody Harrelson role.
-That's right.
-Have you talked to Woody
at all?
-No. I want to.
I want his co-sign.
I want him to tell me like,
"You can do it."
-Oh, yeah,
I think Woody would do that.
You have to talk to him.
You have to meet him.
-Yeah, I feel like he's about
to come out or something.
-No, I wouldn't do that to you.
I wouldn't do that.
I wouldn't do that to you,
I'm sorry.
I wouldn't -- I'm sorry.
-That's how you
always lead it up.
-I know. I'm sorry.
I just get excited.
-"So, have you talked to him?"
-No, no, no.
He pops up like,
"Hey, how you doing?"
He's not here.
Woody, don't come out yet.
[ Laughter ]
He's been under there
the whole time.
-No woodys under there.
-No, wait, no, no.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I just walked
right into that one.
I just walked right
into that one.
I just walked right into it.
-That's okay.
We've had a couple.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-"Come Home the Kids Miss You."
This is out,
just came out Friday.
Can you tell us about the title?
"Come Home the Kids Miss You"?
-I just want to give a shout-out
to my supporters because
they kind of supplied me
with this title.
I was seeing under my comments
for a while,
all my posts,
fans were commenting,
"Come home, the kids miss you."
I just thought it was
such a poetic line.
And then I just -- When I was
sitting and I was like,
"Yo, I need to come up
with an album title."
I realized I spent so much time
away from home
during the making of the album,
and just being swept off
my feet,
being taken around the world,
so I feel like it
encapsulates this era for me.
So we went with it.
-Yeah. You crushed it, buddy.
You got some good features
on here.
Pharrell, Justin Timberlake.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's your guy.
-That's my dude, man.
Lil Wayne. Drake.
I just saw you
at the Kentucky Derby.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Is there any coincidence
that you released your album
the same weekend
as the Kentucky Derby?
-It's not a coincidence.
-Yeah, exactly.
-Had to come home.
-That's a Kentucky boy
right there.
Congrats on everything, man.
You know we love you, man.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's your first talk show
appearance and you nailed it.
So happy for you, bud.
-Appreciate you.
-Very talented guy.
Jack Harlow, "Come Home the Kids
Miss You" is out right now.
Jack is performing for us
after the break.
Come on back.